good morning John so owls are pretty
cool right the big eyes the silent
flight the ears ears but also everybody
knows that owls are cool
what about frog mouse under appreciated
you probably haven't even heard of them
and they're like owls except not at all
despite the big front-facing eyes and
the nocturnal habits frog mouths are
actually more closely related to
hummingbirds than to owls those eyes are
really what does it for us right because
we humans are so I've all focused as a
community based species we see those
eyes as like a sign of intelligence or
emotion and I'm not saying they're not
smart birds are smart but Ravens are
smarter if Ravens had eyes like owls we
would let them teach kindergarten but
then he makes those eyes with this big
ridiculous mouth and you get something
that doesn't really appear wise so much
as alternately hi startled sleepy cranky
shocked and adorably furious frog mouths
our night hunters just like owls hence
the convergent evolution on big front
facing eyes but they mostly bugs though
they will eat a mammal that happens
close enough bye
they have a hard time killing them so
they let's whack them on rocks until
they die but they mostly eat bugs so
instead of big powerful legs they have a
big gigantic mouth the bigger that mouth
got the higher the odds of a successful
catch so the mouths just kept getting
bigger they're so big and if you spend
enough time looking at frog mouths
you'll notice something that also checks
the box of like the human evolutionary
cute brain their heads appear to be like
as big as the whole rest of their body
and that is nearly the case and then if
you go to the next level of like cute
brain check marks turn it into a baby
and it becomes suddenly clear that like
fur bees are infringing on the frogmouth
trademark ah yeah my heart I just want
to squish it frog mouse however are
terrible parents possibly because they
have such tiny useless legs and also
their beaks are so specialized they're
just very bad at nest building they
often lose eggs or chicks to the perils
of that surprise gravity they will take
advantage of the nests of more careful
nests bill
there's or human objects that look like
good nests so that's even cuter let the
Hat but then wait before I go sometimes
they are not cute because they can
shape-shift frog mouths sleep during the
day and they're pretty small so they
have to be wary of predators and they
have in their toolkit a number of ways
to deal with this the first is that they
can just look like logs even will
sometimes sway in the wind like they are
a piece of the tree but when threatened
they can also change shapes too like
scary looking things or just weird
looking like I don't know what to do
with this and the tawny frogmouth of
Australia has like a plan C and D Plan C
assist a peck at the enemy and D is to
spray poop all over it hooray for the
tawny frogmouth you shape-shifting
cryptically disguised poop spraying bug
catching nest neglecting grown-up bird
Furby I love you John I'll see you on
Tuesday also coming up beginning October
28th it's pizza mess it's that time of
the year when John and I pretend like
it's 2007 and we make videos every
single weekday we also sell a number of
Pizza John related products or and saw
this this morning and he pointed and
said that that and I said it's Pizza
John and he said it brings us the pizza
so smart but I have a product that it
wouldn't make sense to sell on October
28th because you need it before then
it's the pizza John Halloween Mass this
is the worst thing we've ever done and I
love it and it's available at dftba.com
I hope that we sell them